you know I know you know eventually you
want you wind up in Fallujah and and but
but can you just talk about sort of you
know like the the realities of War and
what was sort of your first kind of
experiences with with combat and and how
did that kind of fare up to what you
your expectations versus the reality
man I was excited to go do my job I was
on a sniper team I was excited to go
perform my duties outside of Camp
Pendleton California yeah you know I
remember before we actually the reality
of war was that oh look I'm on a base we
have
shitty food perfect we have water that's
rational already this is great
um and then like the first like 72 hours
there like a couple of my leadership and
my team and get like hit by a grenade
they're doing like a left seat right
seat like uh for the outgoing army unit
and I'm like oh
yeah I've never seen anyone injured you
know other than like just basic training
stuff
and I'm like these guys got hit with a
grenade I'm like holy that's real
and then um and what's that feeling man
like what's that is it it's like you're
there but there's like this thing like
with Brotherhood and Sisterhood right
like it's like a shared wait so you're
not holding the whole burden of fear
alone because you know everyone inside
has got like
they have that feeling I can only
imagine I mean I can tell you every time
I've ever suited up to go out the door
um
it's not taken lightly you know no one's
taking it lightly no one's joking uh and
if there's any joking leading up to it
you know that there's that there's a
pause before you exit and you're you're
you're becoming someone different
um you have to
and so in the reality of War for me the
the how it kind of came about was
I had to write it we all had to like
write a death letter
like a death letter this dude comes in
it's like hey you guys gotta write these
letters I'm like
okay and so I kind of like Gaff it off
because like I don't I don't know what
to say I write some shitty letter to my
mom and dad and I write one to my my
girl girl for the time in meaningful but
I'm 18 I don't know what meaningful is I
I have no idea like what reality is out
there for me
and um
you know that day particular my very
first deployment you know that's it was
a new frontier for me I remember we
pulled outside the city of Volusia we
loaded up at like three o'clock in the
man maybe three four o'clock in the
morning super dark outside and people
are smoking you see red lights and
getting those back back of the seven
tons and it just loud and smells like
diesel fuel everywhere and but it's
quite a [__] yeah and um
we leave the base and they call it the
Clover Leaf it was the this like highway
system right outside the Fallujah it was
just down the road maybe like eight to
ten minutes
and so you're like you're bumpy ride
getting there still quite as [__] and
they tell us to get off the trucks and
it's super dark super quiet but we had
these like street lights above us and a
couple guys like start shooting out
these lights it's not like the movies
like there was took a few shots for
these things to happen and I think a
couple of shots probably missed yeah uh
but it was like my first gunshots ever
heard like
inside the wire not on a range and so
that was a little height and leveling
and it's just so quiet and what's even
crazier Fallujah specifically they were
dropping flyers from the sky like days
and weeks prior talking about hey you
have X amount of days to get out of the
city if you're left here you'll be
viewed as combatant hey there's a curfew
like it was there's a lot of Preparatory
work that went into this a lot of psyops
um and how did you think you were going
to be received like you I mean so what's
odd was that our training for this
particular deployment back at home was
called sassa was like uh security and
stability operations and so we're like
doing checkpoints basically like martial
law type of stuff and um like you were
being sent to like police the area and
basically you thought you would be like
kind of welcomed I don't know about
welcome but we were there to like police
the area and
that definitely was like not that was
the mindset for the training back at
home that's what our unit was doing that
wasn't the reality we faced out there I
mean the army guys were just feeling
hammered the whole time they're out
there uh no one knew what to expect it's
like the whole like Mogadishu thing no
one really knew that was what the horn
storm that was about to be stirred up
yeah and uh
I remember us pushing into the City and
um
being the snipers we LED everyone uh
what was kind of like the Ford observers
type of stuff and I remember seeing uh
we had these Mercedes ifabs these like
small little Mercedes Jeeps that our
weapons guys had like machine guns and
like Mark 19s like grenade launchers in
the back and I saw one of those get hit
with a [__] rocket I was like holy
[__] like it's just
silent still even though that's so loud
it's still silent it's just so it was
like eerie
you're like a couple shots nothing
happens I mean something blows up people
get hurt and you're like [__] that's
intense but you're kind of like in the
zone so you just keep on going
and you that kind of repeats itself
until you're you're faced with conflict
where you can't just keep on going
anymore right so like a lot of things
were still kind of like harassing at
this point of time in the day
but it was like holy [__] I just saw
something blow up I just saw some dudes
get [__] up like oh [__] and actually
I'm telling like Hey we're patrolling
down here we're hitting this next house
and we're gonna go set up an OverWatch
position
and I'm the point man so I'm like super
excited but it's also like super intense
and it's very Urban environment which we
didn't do a lot of urban training uh and
fighting in the urban world is [__]
there's Urban movement it's very scary
uh there's a lot of uh unknowns that can
happen was it what you did you expect it
like was it would it look like the way
that you expected like I'm sure you
didn't imagine you could have said you
could have said you're going to anywhere
and I would be like what does that mean
you know technology wasn't a thing I
couldn't google right but flu Asia was
right there was no Instagram videos of
War you know there was you know Fallujah
was like the main thing you know that
people talk about since like Vietnam
like the most gnarliest fighting oif one
which I was not a part of I think it was
still in high school and that happened
you know 2001 I graduated 2003.
According to some of the guys that were
there it was crazy there was like there
was there was death there was
destruction but it was different it was
not as
insane Ed had no idea what that meant
right because I had no comparable
Fallujah was [__] insane it was like
I had all my deployments it was still by
far the craziest scariest
um one I've ever done in my life uh
absolutely [__] terrifying
and uh which is cool in a way I guess
you know I survived that [__] and I'm
able to like articulate it and hopefully
Empower people uh with that type of
background and credibility I guess to
like help people like yeah better
yourself and [__] but at the time I'm
[__] 18 I'm not thinking about
tomorrow I'm worried about today and
um
I remember that my day one in the city
was uh March 26th and uh we hit this
building uh we set up an OverWatch
position on the second floor our job was
to basically
um seven OverWatch position uh report
back anything we saw and then the the
other squads were going to start pushing
forward and we're just clearing like a
big line uh through the city
and
my radar operator and I set up next to
this window and my my team leader my
assistant team leader they're both
School trained Scout snipers so they had
a bolt gun and a pistol so we cleared
this big hump this big house we go
upstairs and sit up we're like super
sneaky squirrely
and um I'm holding Security on the door
that's what a point man does
and I was used to that because I've done
this a few times now in this daytime and
I just wanted to get in the fight I
wanted to participate and like do my job
but I have a very important job making
sure people don't come behind us and
like murder us
and my radar operator is uh he sets up
the radio by the window and he calls out
these two dudes that are across the
street with guns
and so I come to the window and this is
like when all hell breaks out uh we just
started just getting like pelted into
our room uh machine gun rifles
um
and now I'm in a gunfight it's very loud
I'm in an urban building that's very
Hollow it's under construction so every
shot is like vibrating through the house
you have no hearing protection so like
it's
potently loud
um my heart's racing
and it's very violent at this point to
the point where like my my assistant
team leader my team leader they're in
the prone in the on the floor because
they can't engage they have a [__]
sniper rifle and they're fighting a
machine gun and we're already like
vectored into this like one little
opening in a window
and so uh Ben it was his name or is his
name he was on the right side of the
windows on the left side of the window
and we're basically taking turns
shooting whether M4 or M16s and I shoot
Ben shoots I'm like I go to reload and
um I reload my gun and we're fighting
these guys probably like 25 yards away
across the street I call like a Pep Boys
building there's like a bunch of
mufflers and a couple like
all rusted cars on top it looked like it
was like a Pep Boys in Iraq
um
and I reloaded as soon as I come across
that window popped back out I just
lights out I hear this like loud like
this is like life like leave my body
and uh
I had this out of body experience during
a gun fight and um
I didn't really know what that was but I
could just remember seeing I thought it
was dead and I could just I could see my
body I could see the gun fight I don't
know if you ever played a video game
where like you see like the glitch and
you can see like through the walls or in
the rooftop that's what I was seeing I
see the the fighting across the street I
could see my house I could see my body I
could see my team I could see the
stairwell leading up to the room I can
see the smoke billing I see all this
[__] and then um I was like [__] my life
is over
I'm thinking this and then I literally
get sucked back into this light and I
come back into my body and I come back
to like convulsing and [__] and um my my
assistant team leader he's like kicking
me on the ground he's in the Pro and
he's like dude I thought you're [__]
dead and I I came to like crying and
laughing like what the [__] just
happened they're like dude we thought
you were dead we didn't see any blood
and I'm like [__] yeah I don't I don't
know what's really going on at this
point I literally thought I was just
dead
foreign
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world is
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and uh again grateful that you guys tune
in we've decided we want to take things
just a step further it's a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become a part of this
community look I already bored Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with about their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll